- [Instructor] What we're going
to do in this video is show
that if we have two different triangles
that have one pair of sides
that have the same length,
so these blue sides in each
of these triangles have the same length,
and they have two pairs of
angles where, for each pair,
the corresponding angles
have the same measure,
so this gray angle here
has the same measure
as this angle here, and then
these double orange arcs show
that this angle ACB has the same measure
as angle DFE.
And so we're gonna show that
if you have two of your angles
and a side that had the
same measure or length,
that we can always create a
series of rigid transformations
that maps one triangle onto the other.
Or another way to say it,
they must be congruent
by the rigid transformation
definition of congruency.
And the reason why I wrote
angle side angle here
and angle angle side is to realize
that these are equivalent.
Because if you have two angles,
then you know what the
third angle is going to be.
So for example, in this
case right over here,
if we know that we have two pairs
of angles that have the same measure,
then that means that the third pair
must have the same measure as well.
So we'll know this as well.
So if you really think about it,
if you have the side
between the two angles,
that's equivalent to having an
angle, an angle, and a side.
Because as long as you have two angles,
the third angle is also going
to have the same measure
as the corresponding third
angle on the other triangle.
So let's just show a series
of rigid transformations
that can get us from ABC to DEF.
So the first step, you might
imagine, we've already shown
that if you have two
segments of equal length
that they are congruent.
You can have a series
of rigid transformations
that maps one onto the other.
So what I want to do is
map segment AC
onto DF.
And the way that I could do that
is I could translate point A
to be on top of point D,
so then I'll call this A prime.
And then when I do that,
this segment AC is going to
look something like this.
I'm just sketching it right now.
It's going to be in that direction.
But then, and the whole,
the rest of the triangle
is going to come with it.
So let's see, the rest of
that orange side, side AB,
is going to look something like that.
But then we could do another
rigid transformation,
which is rotate about
point D or point A prime,
they're the same point now,
so that point C coincides with point F.
And so just like that,
you would have two rigid
transformations that get us,
that map AC onto DF.
And so A prime, where A is
mapped, is now equal to D,
and F is now equal to C prime.
But the question is where
does point B now sit?
And the realization here is
that angle measures are preserved.
And since angle measures are preserved,
we are either going to have
a situation where this angle,
let's see, this angle is angle CAB
gets preserved.
So then it would be C prime, A prime,
and then B prime would have
to sit someplace on this ray.
Or if we're gonna preserve
the measure of angle CAB,
B prime is going to sit
someplace along that ray.
Because an angle is defined by two rays
that intersect at the vertex
or start at the vertex.
And because this angle is preserved,
that's the angle that is
formed by these two rays.
You could say ray CA and ray CB.
We know that B prime
also has to sit someplace
on this ray as well.
So B prime also has to
sit someplace on this ray,
and I think you see where this is going.
If B prime, because these
two angles are preserved,
because this angle and
this angle are preserved,
have to sit someplace
on both of these rays,
they intersect at one point,
this point right over here
that coincides with point E.
So this is where B prime would be.
So that's one scenario,
in which case we've shown
that you can get a series
of rigid transformations
from this triangle to this triangle.
But there's another one.
There is a circumstance where
the angles get preserved.
But instead of being on,
instead of the angles being on the,
I guess you could say
the bottom right side
of this blue line,
you could imagine the angles get preserved
such that they are on the other side.
So the angles get preserved
so that they are on the
other side of that blue line.
And then the question
is, in that situation,
where would B prime end up?
Well, actually, let me
draw this a little bit,
let me do this a little bit more exact.
Let me replicate these angles.
So I'm going to draw an arc
like this, an arc like this,
and then I'll measure this distance.
It's just like this.
We've done this in other videos,
when we're trying to replicate angles.
So it's like that far,
and so let me draw that on
this point right over here,
this far.
So if the angles are on that side of line,
I guess we could say
DF or A prime, C prime,
we know that B prime
would have to sit someplace on this ray.
So let me draw that as neatly as I can,
someplace on this ray.
And it would have to sit someplace
on the ray formed by the other angle.
So let me see if I can draw
that as neatly as possible.
So let me
make a arc like this.
I probably did that a little
bit bigger than I need to,
but hopefully it serves our purposes.
I measured this distance right over here.
If I measure that distance over here,
it would get us right over there.
So B prime either sits on
this ray, or it could sit,
or and it has to sit, I should
really say, on this ray,
that goes through this
point and this point.
And it has to sit on this ray.
And you can see where
these two rays intersect
is right over there.
So the other scenario is
if the angles get preserved
in a way that they're on the
other side of that blue line,
well, then B prime is there.
And then we could just add
one more rigid transformation
to our series of rigid transformations,
which is essentially or
is a reflection across
line DF or A prime, C prime.
Why will that work, to map B prime onto E?
Well, because reflection is
also a rigid transformation,
so angles are preserved.
And so as this angle gets
flipped over, it's preserved.
As this angle gets flipped over,
the measure of it, I
should say, is preserved.
And so that means we'll
go to that first case
where then these rays would
be flipped onto these rays,
and B prime would have to
sit on that intersection.
And there you have it.
If you have two angles,
and if you have two angles,
you're gonna know the third,
if you have two angles and a side
that have the same measure or length,
if we're talking about angle or a side,
well, that means that they are going
to be congruent triangles.